pierre fait dévier bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt france
pour parler de de ce congrès de la mmf
qu'il y à des enjeux nationaux on va le
voir il y a il y à aujourd'hui et demain
près de 35000 mère qui vont devoir se
prononcer pour désigner le successeur de
françois baroin en quelques mots dit non
à quoi sert la mf et pourquoi cette
élection est elle si importante dans la
vie politique française
oui l'association des maires c'est une
très vieille association qui a été créée
en 1907 et qui regroupe aujourd'hui 34
mille communes sur les 35 mille communes
de france donc c'est une association qui
est extrêmement structurée avec des dés
des structures départementales c'est la
seule d'ailleurs et quelques grandes
missions la première c'est le conseil
juridique auprès des décideurs des
collectivités locales auprès des maires
et des adjoints la formation des élus et
puis et puis le suivi législatif en gros
c'est un peu de lobbying auprès des
parlementaires députés et sénateurs est
une association qui porte également la
voie des de la population au plus près
oui c'est une association qui est par
nature est structurellement proche du
terrain proche des concitoyens savait
que les mères c'est les élus des plus
appréciées des français sont des gens
qui sont donc conclu
effectivement c'est tu sais les maires
sont les plus appréciées parmi les élus
et puis ce sont les élus qui sont les
plus proches des préoccupations des
français donc effectivement c'est un
moyen aussi de faire de relayer le
terrain ce qui se passe sur le terrain
auprès du gouvernement des prêts faits
des parlementaires et donc on a un rôle
à jouer très puissant là dessus et puis
là il ya quelque chose qui se passe en
ce moment sur cette élection là c'est
une originalité il ya deux listes c'est
la première fois et puis ça recouvre
aussi des inquiétudes des élus par
rapport à cette espèce de tentative de
mainmise de l'elysée sur cette belle
association on en parle et vous visiez
c'est une première quasiment
il ya deux listes effectivement
d'habitude il n'y a qu'une liste c'est
un principe philippe laurent candidat de
l'udps et i7 invités et se porte
candidat il est maire de sceaux et il
aurait le soutien et des maquereaux nice
tu sais ce que dit l'opposition en tout
cas emmenés par david lisnard le maire
de cannes ces critiques sont elles
fondées selon vous on va d'abord écouter
ce qu'ont dit les deux principaux
intéressés regarder
il est l'arbre qui cache la forêt macro
nist près de 23 membres de sa liste sur
35 sont proches du chef de l'état s'ils
l'emportent la mf deviendra une courroie
de transmission du pouvoir étatique
philip lawrence est mis entre les mains
d'une mouvance qui veut plaire et servir
emmanuel macron or la mf doit être
indépendante alors ces craintes sont
elles fondées selon vous tiendrez
frédéric blier
oui malheureusement je le crois nous
regarde ça un petit peu de loin mais on
voit bien si ce qui se passait la
composition des listes de monsieur
laurent est plutôt axé vers l'art m et
ce qui est paradoxal si vous voulez
c'est que l'arrêt m'a fait aux
municipales en moyenne des sas et les
chiffres de miss à l'intérieur d'eux
bien que 2 % de l'électorat et on voit
qu'il est nathalie de l'elysée de
pousser la liste de monsieur laurent et
c'est pas la tradition née mf la mf est
indépendante elle a aimé fait là pour
défendre l'intérêt des collectivités des
français et on est très très surpris par
cette tentative de mainmise et c'est
pour ça que david lisnard a eu raison de
repartir sur une liste avec monsieur
laignel savez qu'il ya une tradition en
fait de la droite et de la gauche qui se
mettent d'accord pour défendre l'intérêt
général des collectivités et là on est
tous inquiet par rapport à cette liste
qui est une tentative malheureuse alors
savez en plus le contexte est un peu
compliqué parce que depuis des années
l'assemblée nationale est moins en moins
influencé de plus en plus une chambre
d'enregistrement
et s'il n'y a pas de contre-pouvoirs
comme vous le disiez dans votre vote
reportage on peut s'inquiéter un peu
plus pour notre démocratie alors
pourquoi cet intérêt subitement
d'emmanuel macro on se souvient qu'en en
2017 lorsqu'il s'était rendu au congrès
des maires il avait été bousculé par la
mf il avait été copieusement hué
d'ailleurs il avait même boycotté la mf
l'année suivante pourquoi son son
intérêt soudain
savez même accro a compris il a compris
une chose très importante c'est que
l'ancrage territorial c'est essentiel
quand vous voulez diriger la france
parce qu'il faut avoir des relais
territoriaux locaux et même macron à la
raymond général a échoué largement sur
l'ancrage territorial
donc il ya une tentative de prise de
pouvoir des collectivités par le haut
c'est assez traditionnels de l'art m
haies mais malheureusement je pense que
les maires vont avoir une réaction je
dirais un peu cutanée de cette tentative
de prise de pouvoir par le haut parce
que c'est pas l'intérêt des
collectivités s'est pas attiré des mers
et c'est pas le sens et l'état d'esprit
de la mèche
d'ancrage local la république en marche
n'a pas d'ancrage local pourtant il ya
des mères qui soutiennent cette liste
cette liste
accusé les pro macron oui bah on peut
comprendre il ya les collègues qui voit
aussi l'opportunité de pouvoir peser sur
la mf d'exister au sein de la msa une
belle structure où il ya des
opportunistes politiques c'est tellement
qu'il essayé de la prendre je trouve ça
un peu malheureux parce qu'il faut pas
faire de la politique politicienne avec
la ms c'est une structure qui est
ancienne qui est respectable qui fait un
travail de fonds colossales elle est un
peu méconnue des français d parfois on a
l'impression que ms une espèce de groupe
d'élus qui se réunissent entre eux et
c'est maintenant il ya un travail de
fond il ya un travaillant en lien avec
des différents ministères de notre pays
notamment le ministère de l'intérieur on
agit sont tous qui est conventionnement
collectivités locales police municipale
et caetera et il faut pas en faire une
structure aussi à vis de l'elysée je
prends ce serait une erreur et ça
pourrait mettre en jeu et en cause
l'avenir notre belle association est ce
que le maire de cannes lui même serait
perçu comme une menace pour le président
de la république
je sais pas si j'ai vu comme une menace
en tout cas david lisnard c'est
quelqu'un qui a une colonne vertébrale
idéologique il est aux républicains
depuis très longtemps ce quelqu'un qui
qui fait un travail remarquable sur
cannes c'est le mail élus le maire le
mieux élu de france il est lui à plus de
80% au premier tour quelqu'un kaka une
colonne vertébrale et qui défendra pied
à pied l'un tiré les collectivités parce
que moi j'ai une discussion avec
monsieur laurent je les rencontre il ya
quelques semaines si vous voulez il ya
il ya il ya une question fondamentale
qui se pose sur l'auto me financière des
collectivités qui est inscrit dans la
constitution est bien mieux sur laurent
il constate cette fin d'autonomie dit
que c'est regrettable mais il va pas se
battre pour défendre les collectivités
et moi ça m'a quand même interpellé donc
je pense que david lisnard sera le bon
président pour l'association des maires
alors c'est pas la vie en tout cas de
renaud muselier
de provence-alpes-côte provence alpes
côte d'azur il est pourtant issu de la
même famille politique est de la même
région que david lisnard mais il a
envoyé un courrier à tous les maires
pour soutenir son rival écoutez
congrès des maires 2021 j'ai confiance
en laurent saut pour présider la mf il
est le seul à porter un projet lucide
cohérent structuré fort de son
expérience au sein de l'association
je crois profondément qu'une telle
charge une telle responsabilité ne peut
être légué arbitrairement comme à
l'époque féodale un jour est deux
questions une sur l entente entre les
républicains et d'abord la première est
ce qu'il ne digère pas que françois
baroin et est adoubé évidemment david
lisnard et surtout le fait que
il n'est pas été soutenu par par david
lisnard pour les régionales face à
thierry mariani c'est la politique
politicienne on est d'accord
oui oui il ya définitivement de choses
alors premièrement sent bien que dans le
sud de la france il ya toujours des
dynamites ye qui sont assez ancienne et
qui ressortent à n'importe quelle
occasion
d'élections bon je pense que le courrier
musulmans monsieur muselier qui est un
homme tout à fait respectable et
tellement excessifs qu'ils aient un peu
insignifiant ça c'est la première chose
et puis la seconde chose justement c'est
on ne nomme pas comme à l'époque chez
dale puisqu'il ya deux listes donc me
suis isolé devrait être rassuré les élus
les maires pour pouvoir s'exprimer voter
pour la liste qui le soutiennent très
franchement tout ça c'est un peu c'est
un peu risible à mon avis le fait de
faire parler en tout cas on a réussi à
se connecter avec notre deuxième invité
azzedine à taïbi qui est vert du parti
communiste d'hostun bonjour monsieur
azzedine merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
en direct tels que si vous avez pu
suivre le début de ce débat sur la ms le
fait qu'il ait nié qu'il y ait deux
listes concurrentes en jeu c'est une
première comment est-ce que quelle est
votre réaction par rapport à ces deux
candidatures
alors c'est une première et ça montre à
quel point les les maires sont aussi
très jeune très attaché à la pluralité
même si
évidemment
ne semble pas je n'ai pas souvenir après
je suis aussi un jeune mère je suis
bientôt depuis 2014 certainement que mon
collègue de dreux
doit peut-être se souvenir qu'il
existait ce type de situation je ne suis
pas certain
c'est la première fois voilà donc vous
confirmez donc bonjour chers collègues
maires de deux jours donc si
c'est une première et c'est tant mieux
ça prouve que malgré tout malgré nos nos
sensibilités diverses et variées ou
simple de la mf il y à aussi c'est le
ventre de pluralité exprimé par par les
maires et je pense qu'il n'y a pas de
hasard on a on a vécu un épisode est
kiné qui n'est pas finie loin d'être
finie qui est la crise du coc vide et je
pense que
les maires on plus qu'une parole ont un
témoignage plus qu'un témoignage sont
vraiment les relais des gérer des
situations extrêmement critique
compliqué sur le sur le terrain on est
vraiment on est vraiment sur le terrain
on a voilà on est on est face aux
difficultés
diverses que nous connaissons auprès de
nos populations donc ça prouve que au
sein du congrès des maires et dans sa
représentativité qui est sera je
l'espère effective d'ici quelques jours
à la fin du progrès
cette pluralité cette diversité c'est
ses voix au pluriel seront bien
évidemment entendu au sein du congrès
des maires je voudrais quand même bon on
n'a pas vraiment aussi salué le travail
de de l'ancien enfin de du président
actuel
baroin le maire de le maire de te donne
2 3 qui a qui a quand même mené un
travail extrêmement important au sein de
la mf du jeu je le dis et pourtant il ne
fait pas partie de ma sensibilité mais
il faut je le reconnais il faut bien
reconnaître que il a aussi su aussi
entendre l'expression des mères dans
leur diversité
dans les difficultés que pour lesquelles
nous sommes confrontés sur le terrain
ses instincts à dreux je pense que c'est
les mêmes difficultés que mon collègue
rencontre aussi seront sur le terrain
est donc cette parole des mères est
derrière cette parole des mères c'est la
parole aussi des habitants c'est la
parole de la pompe de la proximité doit
de mon point de vue être davantage
entendue aujourd'hui et demain mais
aussi par l'exécutif représenté par ce
gouvernement et par le président de la
république donc c'est c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle pour la démocratie même
si en ce moment la situation est
extrêmement difficile a dit françois
baroin qui a été perçu quand même comme
l'un des des opposants aussi au pouvoir
central apparaît à emmanuel macron
certains disent que le fait qu'il y ait
la candidature de philippe laurent
soutenu par la république en marche
c'est une menace de non ingérence
d'ingérence en tout cas de l'exécutif
dans la mf qu'en pensez vous
évidemment on voit bien que la
candidature de monsieur laurent et est
quand même une candidature on va dire
assez assez politique et qui vient en
tous les cas
s'intercaler dans le calendrier
électoral
pour les prochains mois je le regrette
très franchement est d'ailleurs quoi
faire pour ma part je ne sais pas le jeu
ne s'est pas le choix de monsieur mais
de mon collègue et maire de dreux pour
ma part mon choix n'est pas celui ci mon
choix et portait plutôt sur une liste
avec un candidat qui prendra en compte
je dirais les sensibilités diverses et
variées des mères mais qui prendra
sociale surtout en compte notre
aspiration à faire en sorte que
l'échelon communal l'échelon municipal
est un échelon nécessaire et essentielle
tellement utile et on l'a prouvé durant
la crise qu vide pour pour nos habitants
donc la proximité la solidarité le lien
avec nos habitants et est pour moi
quelque chose d'essentiel sinon je
n'aurais aucun intérêt de m'engager en
tant qu' en tant que maire comme je le
fais aujourd'hui comme d'autres
d'ailleurs quelle que soit leur
sensibilité parce que voilà c'est c'est
une très compliqué donc voilà je vais
bien sûr je regrette mes mots quand je
dirais je reviens je ne suis pas non
plus surpris mais donc voilà mais bon ça
fait partie de peut-être aussi du jeu
politique certainement quoi avoir un
ancrage c'est ce qu'on disait avec
pierre fériés avoir un ancrage pour
emmanuel macron un ancrage local qu'il
n'a pas pour l'instant
tout à fait tout à fait on avr on l'a
bien vu dans les élections qui se sont
déroulées il ya maintenant quelques
quelques mois mais l'ancrage local il se
construit aussi il se construit dans la
durée il se construit aussi à partir je
dirais une expérience à partir aussi
d'une confiance qu'il faut qu'il faut
qu'il faut établir sur le terrain elle
n'est pas elle n'est pas acquise comme
ça du jour au lendemain les cr véritable
parcours du combattant et bon collègue
maire de drogue doit aussi et contre
confrontés aux mêmes difficultés donc
voila c'était c'est un combat du
quotidien et de la proximité pierre on
va écouter le gérard larcher le patron
du sénat qui a donné son onction lui
aussi à la candidature de david lisnard
garde
rien ne serait pire que l'alignement de
l'association des maires de france sur
la politique menée par le gouvernement
quel qu'il soit il en va de sa
crédibilité de sa survie à l'idée que
c'est une question de survie vous êtes
d'accord avec ça
oui parce que comme le dit mon collègue
de stains cesser ce qui se passe
actuellement est assez inquiétant pour
l'association des maires il ya une
reprise une tentative de reprise en main
par l'elysée la mf qui n'a jamais été
fait auparavant faut regarder la liste
de david lisnard elle est plutôt bien
faite il ya monsieur laignel qu'il a
depuis 2008 en tant que premier
vice-président qui garantissent 10 et
équilibre entre la droite et la gauche
avec des maires qui sont non encartés
ils essaient de défendre l'intérêt des
collectivités locales des mairies parce
qu'il ya les mairies mais aussi des jeux
pc il faut pas l'oublier c'est toujours
important et puis c'est la garantie d'un
travail qui va continuer pour défendre
les intérêts de toutes les collectivités
des mers peu importe leur étiquette
politique je le répète la reine a fait 2
5 2% en moyenne aux élections
municipales il ya quelques mois vouloir
prendre la main sur la dmf franchement
c'est une insulte aux réalités de
terrain et l'idée de ce qu'on vit nous
en tant que maire et en tant qu'élu ça
peut avoir une incidence je pose une
question un peu name et sur l'élection
présidentielle est ce que c'est une
tentative aussi pour peser pour la
présidentielle ou est ce qu'il ya des
cloisons oui oui oui et puis l'air de
rien il ya quand même les parrainages
qui sont dans l'air
voilà il ya beaucoup de demandes de
parrainage il ya des mères alors moi je
suis je suis encarté comme le maire de
stains là où ont clairement on sait où
on est mais il ya des maires ruraux qui
veulent soutenir tel ou tel petit
candidat parce que c'est aussi
l'expression la démocratie de la
pluralité il faut que ce serait il faut
le respecter l'apli en main par l'elysée
de la ms sur les parrainages et
l'expression démocratique
on peut s'interroger c'est tout à fait
légitime c'est votre avis également être
in time et la question des parrainages
est extrêmement important d'autant que
ces parrainages son public bien sûr tout
à fait moi je partage ce que veut dire
mon collègue j'y vois aussi de pour ma
part et là je le suis et quelque part
très inquiète comme une tentative de
créer un je dirais main basse sur
l'association des maires de france
alors que jusqu'à maintenant elle a
plutôt démontré qu'elle prenait en
compte
la diversité des sensibilités et que
représente cette association donc il ya
ya presque pour moi un hold-up anti
démocratique est en train de s'effectuer
c'est vraiment insoutenable il n'en
n'est pas à son premier coup
valeureusement le pouvoir
dedans marche si on ne sent pas à son
premier coup et est ce que je vois aussi
c'est une fort je dirais de pression qui
est fortement appuyé sur les mers je
dirais sans étiquette comme vous l'avez
précisé beaucoup sont recensés étiquette
de quelle manière ces pressions de
quelle manière ces pressions c'est
évidemment bon jeu j'ose espérer que
l'issue du scrutin permettra à ce que la
liste des senneurs puisse est largement
élu mais si c'était le cas inverse je
peux vous dire qu'au lendemain du
congrès de l'adf les bataillons les
quelques bataillons du pouvoir en marche
mettront générait toute leur énergie
pour aller à la rencontre des maires
sans étiquette
et puis quelque part aussi leur mettre
un petit peu la pression parce que voilà
vous savez malheureusement parfois c'est
du donnant donnant je pense qu'il faut
sortir il faut sortir de ce de cette
posture politicienne qui pour moi
néfaste pour la démocratie mais en plus
très très mauvaise pour les élus que
nous sommes les mères que nous sommes on
est confronté sur le terrain a beaucoup
de difficultés ce que l'on demande à
l'exécutif c'est non pas d'être dans des
tracts dans des tractations politiques
mais c'est de répondre véritablement ou
aux besoins et aux attentes de la
population
et moi je me retrouve totalement dans la
proposition la liste lisnard qui qui
garde sept cette démarche qui était déjà
initiés auparavant par françois bach 1
et comme l'a dit mon collègue qui va la
poursuivre voire même je le souhaite
même l'amplifier pour donner encore plus
un sens et une cohérence dans le rôle
des maires et des élus que nous sommes
sur le terrain c'est de cela qu'il
s'agit à mon avis je pense que là il ya
vraiment un danger oui je peux le dire
un danger démocratique mon point de vue
merci beaucoup ce sera le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup à la saisine taibi pour
votre participation merci à vous qui
aviez
pour avoir débattu même si vous êtes
d'accord on ne savait pas un pour qui
vous allez voter je le précise merci
beaucoup à tous les deux de nous avoir
éclairé si sur ces enjeux